it used to be my chip on my shoulder I
think about my my children they've got a
great mum and dad who's supporting 100
of the way they give him confidence they
give him belief when you haven't got
that you need to find it from inside and
the fingers especially when men what we
find we're doing is we're always proving
ourselves like there's a certain
calmness about someone that's from a
nice stable background but when you
haven't had that Advantage it's in you I
was always proving myself always having
to be the loud one always having to be
like the cocky self-assured you know
possibly you know that fine line between
confidence and arrogance I think I
stepped on the wrong line quite a lot of
the time I think that was true and I've
learned about that and the difference
really for me is now like I everyone I
work with especially in that predicament
I feel like I'm there dad